we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p this voicemail uh dives into
a very controversial issue of iq
education and financial success let's
listen to
how the caller frames it up take a
listen to this hey david
um please please please perform an
analysis
and explain this anomaly if more
education correlates with higher
income level education correlates with
buddha intelligence
why did 54 of the voters earning more
than 100k
vote for trump okay explain this and i
will forever address you as sir
and i will forgive you for referring to
the university of pennsylvania as you
pen
all right take care of my friends oh my
god i didn't know you weren't supposed
to say you pen
uh no list so there's a couple things
going on the link
between iq and income
is only correlated in a certain part of
the band and what i mean by that
is if you have a really low iq to the
point at which
it would identify a cognitive issue
that has a very negative impact on
earning potential
but what you see is that once you get if
i'm
trying to remember this is this is a
nasim talib has written about this
once you get just a little bit above
average iq
you don't see much of an earnings
premium
as iq goes up higher and higher uh
and so i i think that maybe the premises
here
aren't quite right um and in particular
if you set the bar at a hundred thousand
dollars
there are tons of people without college
degrees
who um earn a hundred thousand dollars
there are lots of trades
in which you can earn a hundred thousand
dollars so i i think that you know
i'm glad to address the issue of income
and voting tendencies and you have to
remember that
uh the one reason that people with
higher incomes
regardless of education level and
regardless of intelligence
might lean republican and this is a
historical reality
is because as someone with a higher
income they may see
uh that republicans will make them pay
less in taxes
and so i think that you know you're sort
of on to something
interesting and exploring but some of
the premises there are not quite right
on the bonus show today we will talk
about caitlyn jenner's
run for california governor running
as a republican what will the trans
community think
of a republican trans candidate what
will california republicans think
of a trans candidate a lot of
interesting dynamics there
we will also talk about joe biden
recognizing the armenian genocide
as a genocide which armenians
liked and the turkish folks did not and
there is a lot of controversy
around this we will also talk about joe
biden wanting to make
community college free but progressives
aren't satisfied with that
what more might progressives be able to
get from joe biden
on that where are we on debt
cancellation a lot to talk about with
joe biden and education
those stories and more on today's bonus
show to get instant access to the bonus
show
it's very simple you go to
joinpakman.com
and you sign up that's it and i will see
you on the bonus show
in mere moments